We're in the middle of our small business challenge
where two entrepreneurs compete to win a prize package
which includes $10,000.
(audience clapping)
And joining me is the incredible co-judge.
I can't believe it, it's Daymond John.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Okay, before the break Justin and Jasmine pitched
their businesses Morning Joy Co.
and now it's time for our next entrepreneur
to make her case.
Please say hello to Tamarha Walker,
the owner of Queen Bee Jelly.
Tamarha, what is your pitch and why should you win?
So with Queen Bee Jelly,
have you ever gone through work?
And just like, "I can't do this anymore.
I'm so over this."
Well, if not, I did, I was heading up the escalators.
I just got off the training Washington DC
into amazing law firm.
And I said, this can't be life.
It has to be more to it.
And so I've always been a fan of clothing
but I knew that there was more to it.
I had to really understand like
but what is it about clothes?
We all love to look good
but it was more along the lines of the textures and prints
and all that beauty of fabric.
So that's when I realized
I wanted to open Queen Bee Jelly Modern Fabrics,
and with Queen Bee Jelly,
we specialize in Ankara.
And Ankara is this beautiful fabric
that is originally created in Holland.
It's a big staple in the African community.
I want people to feel excited when they see this fabric.
I want them to be inspired.
And that's the whole beauty of Queen Bee Jelly
is for folks to see the fabric and just be inspired.
Thank you so much, Tamarha.
Daymond, what is your question?
I think it's beautiful fabrics job.
How are you selling it now?
Is it people buying it for them to make dresses
or as for curtains, drapes bedding or all of it?
Actually folks are buying it for apparel,
for clothing and also for upholstery.
You can use it for your drapes,
for your chairs, your couches, all of the above.
Now what are your sales?
So I have a total of monthly.
It can be about (murmurs)
at least 200 sales.
Okay, excellent.
I fell in love with your fabrics.
I think they are so artistic.
When I'm like just pitching an idea to a Walmart
or whatever businesses I'm working with.
A lot of the times I'll hear what's the Google search.
And it's a big thing
that people really care about in business.
And when I was Google searching your business
I had a little trouble with the Queen Bee Jelly.
And I think if there's a way to bring in
that Modern Fabrics to the forefront,
you'll be quicker to find.
'Cause once I got to your social,
which I know you're not the biggest fan of social
but your social is really good.
So I just wanna make sure that Modern Fabrics is in there
to set you apart 'cause Queen Bee Jelly
and I understood all the meaning behind it.
I wanted to see that Modern Fabrics in there
as much as possible.
By Modern Fabrics might beat Queen Bee Jelly,
'cause Queen Bee Jelly.
All three of those words are very common words.
And that's why you try to create companies
named The FUBU or Google or Nike,
words that don't necessarily exist.
Because then you'll have problems Google searching it
or trademarking it in various countries and territories.
So it's important to differentiate it.
It's a detail I felt compelled to tell you
'cause I think your taste is impeccable.
Beautiful.
All right.
It's time for Daymond and I to deliberate.
So we're gonna put you guys on mute
so we can speak honestly
and then we'll get right back to you.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
Okay, Daymond thoughts?
First of all, fashion is something that I,
obviously I'm here because of fashion.
But when I asked Tamarha her sales she had to think.
That means that she's not that good with her numbers
and her data.
Where you looked at the Cut Board,
they knew their sales, they knew their units.
They knew how many people responded.
They knew how many stars they had.
And in a very short period of time,
they showed they were only out I think, a year, right.
And they showed a good amount of that
in a very short period of time.
In a tough year.
Yeah.
Too.
A tough year, you're right.
In a year where people were not spending a lot.
I also think that they have an interesting angle
and I would like to see them bring their branding
into their business a little more
because I wasn't totally aware
that you could do the custom recipes and customize it.
So I feel like they need to bring that into their name too.
'Cause Morning Joy Company
doesn't automatically ring custom boards for me.
All right.
So we've made our decision.
I think so yeah.
Let's bring them back please.
Okay, both of you guys are just incredible
and there can only be one winner.
So Justin and Jasmine, you are today's winner.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, wow.
You are going to go home with a feature on our homepage
of our show's website at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
a consultation with award winning PR Executive,
Susan Magrino who launched Martha Stuarts career.
Cuisinart Virgin Atlantic coach, and $10,000 from bill.com.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much.
Thank you, wow.
That's incredible.
And Tamarha, you are not going home empty handed.
You're also gonna receive a thousand dollars.
And I am going to put my brain
to think of how to work with you.
You are one of the very first companies
that I found personally, out of the 75,000 entries.
I fell in love with you.
I wanna work with you with our flower brands.
So this is the beginning of something
I would love to collaborate with you...
(upbeat music)